[Music]
on this tuesday night gridlock at a busy
border crossing we're putting the
pressure because we want the attention
the latest protest this time at a
crucial route between the u.s and canada
saskatchewan's premier plans to drop all
public health restrictions plus the
pressure on other provinces to do the
same a decision was made to wedge to
divide and to stigmatize the liberal mp
criticizing his own government's
handling of the pandemic and a tale of
two olympic experiences american-born
athletes representing china in beijing
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight at one of the busiest
international border crossings the
latest place to be targeted by
protesters demanding an end to all
public health restrictions in canada
this blockade of the ambassador bridge
began last night it is the busiest land
border crossing in north america and a
major route for transport trucks the
ambassador bridge stretches from windsor
ontario to detroit michigan it accounts
for over 25 percent of the two-way
traffic between the two countries
roughly eight thousand trucks daily
about thirty percent of the trade
between canada and the us uses the
bridge
the blockade isn't just affecting the
flow of goods many people who live in
the windsor area including essential
workers use it to commute and the
closures are causing massive delays at
other ports of entry too our sean o'shea
is in windsor ontario tonight sean
donna windsor police were caught off
guard by this protest on monday and now
as a result all truck traffic in canada
has been stopped
protesters who opposed mandatory
vaccinations and mass mandates are
blocking the area behind the canada
border services agency checkpoints in
effect closing off all traffic saying
they have the right
our lives have been hijacked for two
years
literally hijacked
this was the lineup of trucks on the
detroit side now they've been diverted
to a less convenient and distant
crossing at sarnia ontario it doesn't
make sense to disturb the
rest of the public right so
they they shouldn't be blocking the
borders and they shouldn't be blocking
the roads
the protest also affected u.s bound
trucks this was the long lineup of
trucks in windsor waiting to cross such
blockades will have serious implications
on our economy on our supply chain the
shutdown didn't take much planning or
heavy equipment only a handful of big
rigs plus pickup trucks and protesters
on foot police watching and blocking
access roads nothing more but we're
putting the pressure because we want the
attention
we want our cause to be heard shutting
down the bridge is a way that these
people have bonded together here to say
hey listen we're trying to get attention
so there can be communication this trade
route more than others in canada
supports auto manufacturing and other
key industries delays of any kind are
bad for business it's urgent that
governments do everything possible to
ensure a peaceful resolution immediately
windsor police told us their job is to
try to keep the peace as for any kind of
enforcement removing the trucks or
reopening the border there are no plans
to do that here not right now
donna
all right shawn o'shea in windsor
ontario thanks protesters have demanded
all public health restrictions be
dropped including the lifting of mass
mandates and other measures imposed by
provincial and civic governments today
saskatchewan springer outlined his
province's plans to do that premier
scott mo says as of monday proof of
vaccination to enter indoor venues will
no longer be required mass mandates and
isolation requirements are said to be
removed at the end of the month
late today alberta's premier said the
time has come to live with covid jason
kenney is beginning to lift public
health restrictions what he calls a path
back to normal and he is ending the
proof of vaccine requirement as of
midnight tonight
the threat of covet 19
to public health is no no longer
outweighs the hugely damaging impact of
health restrictions on our society on
people's mental health on their
emotional well-being on
our broader social health
so now is the time to begin learning to
live with covid
there remain more than fifteen hundred
people with covet in hospital in alberta
our heather europe's west is in kutz
alberta where protesters resumed a
border blockade heather what are they
telling you tonight
well they've been listening to
the developments from the premier very
closely we know that as you mentioned as
of midnight tonight the proof of vaccine
program will end next week school
children will no longer have to wear
masks to school from there on march 1st
the indoor mask mandate will also be
lifted this is something that protesters
have been asking for but will it be
enough for them to end their their
protest that is now into its second week
likely not the protesters i've spoken
with say they also want to see an end to
federal vaccine mandates
even a change in government
i'm sick of having my kids wear their
masks in school i don't my daughter
breathing carbon monoxide in and out all
day hopefully the mandates get dropped
and then uh
it'd be nice if trudeau took a flying
hike
if he could he could get
get lost
i think he meant carbon dioxide heather
authorities say the blockade is illegal
how are the
rcmp likely to respond
well rcmp told us today that they have
uh two major objectives here one is to
maintain the peace the other is to
ensure that border access uh remains
open as well as access to the local
community now at this hour i can tell
you
most of this afternoon that is happening
traffic is getting through the border uh
the mayor of kutz says that he does not
want to see um
the rcmp take a heavy-handed approach to
protesters adding that many of these
protesters are actually members of the
community
i just mentioned that the people that
are protesting are your neighbor from
down the road and so it's not the kind
of guys that are trying to wreck stuff
and create noise and and pollution and
doing all the stuff that you heard of
other places
and so it requires a different treatment
from the rcmp
still rcmp say there have been illegal
activity at this protest over the past
week they have investigations open and
they say charges will be laid the
alberta government is saying that this
is an illegal protest an illegal
blockade it needs to end
whether that will happen now that the
alberta premier has
outlined a plan to lift restrictions
provincially that is something that we
will have to wait and see donna
all right we will heather york's weston
coots alberta thank you now in ottawa
the protest there was quieter today
there is a court injunction in place to
stop the honking and police say they've
issued more tickets and made more
arrests lots of trucks remain on the
streets near parliament hill though and
as ross lord reports police say there
are children in many of those trucks
[Music]
on the first full day of a court ruling
that limits noise from truck horns the
occupation at the foot of parliament
hill is quieter but after allowing the
protesters to become embedded here
ottawa city police insist they are
determined to get rid of them there is
absolutely a need to end this we are
actively working to do it through
peaceful
progressive negotiations but we also
have looked at enforcement angles to
move ascend but how soon
to follow through city police say they
need an additional 1800 officers and
civilian personnel from other police
agencies it's unclear how many have been
procured the federal government through
the rcmp has been proactive in providing
a tangible concrete support by assigning
275 rcmp officers who are now working
closely with
the ops the opp to enforce community
safety ottawa police say they've made 22
arrests issued more than 1300 tickets
and there are dozens of ongoing criminal
investigations including one following
the alleged attack of an officer if and
when the time comes to remove these
vehicles it's unclear who will do the
moving every company on the city of
ottawa's go-to list of tow truck drivers
has rejected requests to move heavy
vehicles from downtown they rely on
heavy truck industry for their
livelihood and they don't want to damage
that part of their business polling
shows a clear majority of canadians
oppose the occupation but protesters say
they've received enormous support from
people driving to ottawa mostly from
other parts of ontario if you think that
this is just a fringe movement and
there's only a small percentage of
canadians think there's something
nefarious going on with their government
and in our country then you're dreaming
for police there are numerous
considerations they say almost a quarter
of the 418 trucks encamped in the city
have children living in them
complicating any discussion of how to
proceed with a possible operation we're
not at the stage of looking
to do any sort of
enforcement activity around that we'll
rely on the children's aid society to
help provide and give us guidance around
that still more questions than answers
as the occupation continues
ross lord global news ottawa
the protests are taking a toll including
on businesses in ottawa and they're
racking up policing costs a little later
we'll take a closer look at some of
those costs
first a liberal mp from quebec has
publicly criticized his own government's
policies and provincial public health
measures joel lightbound says political
leaders have failed to explain their
rationale for keeping restrictions in
place and are causing division by their
unwillingness to adapt as david aiken
explains lightbound wants a clear road
map to returning to normal david well
donna you know the prime minister has
responded to these convoy protests by
arguing they represent a minority that
most canadians are united on the
importance of vaccine mandates and so on
well today justin trudeau cannot even
claim his own caucus is united on that
point i can't help but notice with
regret that both the tone and the
policies of my government changed
drastically on the eve and during the
last election campaign joel lightbaum
became the first liberal mp to call for
a roadmap to end vaccine mandates to end
vaccine passports and he claimed other
liberals feel the same i can tell you
that i'm not the only one who feels
to varying degrees
as i do within our ranks elected to a
quebec city area riding in 2015
lightbound has been a liberal mp with
promise among other things he's been
parliamentary secretary to the finance
minister an appointment that is often a
prelude to going into cabinet now he's
resigned as chair of the quebec liberal
caucus and he says his own party is part
of the problem a decision was made to
wedge to divide and to stigmatize
we conservatives could not agree more
while conservatives cheered the prime
minister seemed sympathetic i can
understand frustrations with mandates
but mandates
are the way to avoid further
restrictions or having to be restricted
as people get vaccinated as canadians
have gotten vaccinated we've been able
to get through things but a new poll out
tuesday found 44 of vaccinated
respondents said they sympathize with
the concerns and frustrations of
parliament hill protesters in any event
light bound will find his caucus
colleagues disagree with what he did and
how he did it i got some problems with
it frankly the politici i think he said
that the debate has been politicized i
think saving lives is much more than a
political debate it's a fact and it's
something we need to do and it's
something we've been relentless in doing
over the last two years lightbound says
he wants to remain a liberal but some in
the party may seek to toss him out of
the national caucus altogether when it
meets behind closed doors wednesday
morning donna
all right david aiken in ottawa thanks
on the same team but a world apart
coming up the different experiences of
two u.s foreign athletes representing
china at the winter games
the winter olympic games are an
opportunity for athletes to showcase
their talents on the world stage it is
supposed to be all about athletic
achievement but politics inevitably
seeps in eric sorenson has the story of
two u.s born athletes who have chosen to
compete for china at the games
eileen gu may be the biggest star of
these olympics and that was before her
spectacular double cork 1620 to win gold
in the free ski big air she is known as
the snow princess in china she has
multiple endorsement deals and she
happens to be american raised in
california goo decided to compete for
china the birthplace of her mother and
like so much about these games politics
now weighs heavily on her story her
post-victory news conference peppered
with questions about choosing china over
america here's the thing i'm not trying
to keep anyone happy i'm an 18 year old
girl out here living my best life like
i'm having a great time picking china
symbolizes for some an ascendant nation
this beijing resident says it proves
china's sports and commercial
environment is superior to the united
states but only to a point zhu yi
another american-born athlete competed
for china but when she fell more than
once in figure skating it was not only
heartbreaking for her it angered many
chinese that she was selected over
home-grown athletes attacked on social
media for stealing other people's dreams
chinese censors stepped in from a uyghur
athlete lighting the olympic cauldron to
a tennis player disavowing earlier
claims of sexual abuse critics say the
host country is using the olympics to
whitewash its image and no images seemed
more politically charged than the
leaders of china and russia meeting
during the games a desire to assert for
their own countries a place on the world
stage the fact is that sports
has been political from the beginning of
time and every olympics has had an
element of politics meantime eileen gu
has been denounced by some back in the
u.s everything about her is awful
goo could be beloved in either china or
the u.s but not it seems in both during
these politicized games eric sorensen
global news toronto
a former canadian women's soccer coach
has pleaded guilty to three counts of
sexual assault and one count of sexual
touching charges against bob berarda
were laid over a year ago for crimes
committed between 1988 and 2008. he was
the head coach of the vancouver
whitecaps women's team and the canadian
under 20 women's team both organizations
cut ties with him in 2008. more than a
dozen women have come forward with
allegations bharata acted
inappropriately
protests come with a cost ahead how the
disruptions are affecting businesses and
trade
you're watching global national
[Music]
there's some good news tonight for
potato farmers in pei the u.s has agreed
to resume shipments of island potatoes
to puerto rico that represents about a
quarter of pei's potato exports to the
u.s those experts have been on hold
since november when potato wart was
discovered in two pei fields the fungus
poses no threat to human health but can
reduce crop yields puerto rico does not
farm potatoes commercially so the risk
is low
well bands like that have a big economic
impact the ongoing so-called freedom
convoy protests are also having an
impact there are huge costs to the city
of ottawa for policing and lots of small
businesses already battered by the
pandemic have had to close tonight ann
gaviola takes a look at the economic
costs of these protests
it's really disheartening first bite
treats in ottawa's byward market started
the year off with a lockdown then the
protest convoy descended on nearby
parliament hill the financial toll is
significant as people and delivery
services shun the downtown core
it's in the thousands uh and it's
racking up doritos center ottawa's
largest mall with 175 shops has been
closed since the weekend affecting
thousands of employees and neighboring
businesses
mall owner cadillac fairview says the
continued closure of an important
community space loss of employment
income and the financial impact on
clients is heartbreaking given our
shared pain and sacrifice during the
pandemic
policing costs for the city of ottawa
are eight hundred thousand for policing
plus one million dollars in city
services every day the city is asking
for help from provincial and federal
governments including eighteen hundred
more officers which would bring daily
policing costs to two and a half million
dollars
for context security for a canada day
celebration runs north of six hundred
thousand dollars this eclipses that
uncertainty about how long this drags on
could mean long-term damage to tourism
hospitality and retail even if they
leave next week could they be back in a
month did they be back in two months
with cross-border traffic disrupted
analysts expect the price of goods
trucked in to go up the longer this
continues especially food and that's on
top of existing supply chain related
inflation the rcmp tell global news they
don't yet have a tally of policing costs
to taxpayers as multiple divisions are
involved but they'll have one soon the
mental cost that this can actually place
on people
is something we haven't thought about
but it's something that should be
considered this could be a major
disruption uh if the government can't
find a way to bring this back under
control and unite everybody politically
socially and economically the biggest
price to pay may not be easy to put into
dollars and cents
anne gaviola global news toronto
[Music]
let's talk about the oscars then next
can this year's nominees still spice up
the big screen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the stage is set for hollywood's biggest
night the 2022 oscar nominations are out
and once again the box office is no
longer playing a lead role half of the
movies nominated for best picture either
debuted or were quickly released on
streaming platforms mike derlay reports
on the evolution of the movie business
and the oscar
goes to
there was a time the oscars would
routinely draw over 40 million viewers
last year fewer than 10 million watched
a show that lacks songs spectacle and
star power are the oscars still even
relevant i think they think they are i
don't know if any awards
ceremony now that there are more than
four channels and that you can avoid the
oscars on the sunday night that they
happen if you want to i don't think any
award ceremony has that level of
importance
the last year was another tough one for
the movie industry memories of pack
theaters and blockbusters seem distant
you're the nominees for best picture of
the 10 movies nominated for best picture
most including west side story nightmare
alley and belfast have yet to make money
at the box office king richard and dune
from canadian double nominee denis
villeneuve were released in theaters and
streaming services at the same time the
others including the power of the dog
with its 12 nominations are streamers
the industry's in transition even if
movie lovers believe epics like dune are
meant for the big screen i don't think
theaters will ever go away i think
streaming has carved out a bigger space
than anyone would have expected in the
time allotted but that's mostly because
of the pandemic forcing everyone to stay
home watch movies at home and realize
you know if you have a pretty decent
setup it's cheaper it's more comfortable
and you can not leave your house i'd
like you to take me with you
whether it's a distant world or the old
west movies still captivate us
you are marvelous rose
and that golden oscar no matter how many
people watch
is still the ultimate prize for those
who set out to captivate
mike relay global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is kimberly british columbia
there are beautiful spots all over this
country please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye